this episode of riding with grace is
sponsored by silliness aha you've been
praying there is actually I'm riding
with grace video this week even though I
told you that there was it thanks change
get used to it have fun riding with
grace it's ready with grace cuz I really
don't want to write this whole thing by
myself it's riding with grace riding
with me me my name is Grace welcome to
another episode of riding with grace
first of all I have to say a huge huge
thank you to all of you that have been
super supportive of this new series and
have participated in the most amazing
way and you exceeded expectations beyond
measure I am so thankful good job you
last week I asked you guys to write
chapter 2 a freak week you guys got your
freak on and things got citrusy more on
that later but before I tell you which
submission I've chosen to continue our
novella freak week let's get into some
silly statistics wow what a punch that
packed here are some statistics that
we've noticed from your submissions over
the last week the oldest person to
submit chapter two a freak week with 56
years old but I don't like to call them
the oldest because I think that has a
negative connotation so I like to say
they are the closest to that death kiss
congratulations
you should be proud at least for your
submission paintings I am glad to see
you guys support a very specific part of
the periodic table we got over 250
submissions in total which is more than
249 well thank you guys and we got
submissions from every single continent
except Antarctica
what are you doing penguins I fought
very hard so that every single continent
could participate in writing with grace
and then you just chose not to I'm just
so disappointed in you penguins you have
so many movies about how great you are
and I asked you for one favor
moving on each week in addition to
announcing our choice chapter I will be
announcing some silly
and with grace Awards in a segment I'm
calling silly the Pearl is the first
award is for best dialogue let me
consult my notes here it is it's for
Wattpad user primo Janita the line is
quote yeah she's weird and that's coming
from me and I listen to polka music to
fall asleep bellowed Marmee
congratulations primo chanita i lolled
at that line our next award is the best
surprise surprise award for best
surprise prize goes to Wattpad user
lizzie robertson one she introduced us
to the best character ever her Marmee
character decided to keep one of the
shih tzus that had fallen from the sky
and named it jeans congrats on the
creation of jeans I loved it next best
prom responded we had two prompts the
first prompt was to describe crush the
main characters crush in the novella and
the award goes to walk that user and x
ll why why why why because why have any
other username but that I mix lol why
why why why's description of crush is
simply crush has grapefruit Headroom
I've been told I have a meatloaf face so
maybe that's why I enjoyed it so much I
related to it ha I did not see that
coming the other prompt that we asked
you guys for was to create day to a
freak week and that is what
environmental disaster or change happens
that changes our story and the winner is
Alex Fowler 8 so we decided to create
freak week day two as a key lime lime
attack meaning that the characters got
chased by mimes throwing key lime pies
at them which I feel like Alex you've
just had this in your subconscious for
maybe years and you finally had an
outlet to like put it into a piece of
fiction
who knows if this is fiction this might
have actually happened to you in your
life and if it did I'm very sorry and
that brings us to our chapter choice for
chapter 2 of freak week can I get a
weak and well-intentioned drumroll Diane
are you trying to make it polka sounding
my two hands aren't in our chapter
choices from Wattpad user pseudonym for
me they wrote a chapter called musical
malaise Wow Wow Brian use crap get
better and better every week I gotta
tell you I love this chapter so much and
if you guys haven't checked it out
already please check it out
synonym for me your user photo on
Wattpad as a dog which I am so intrigued
by because what and also are you a dog
that wrote this chapter because that's
something I've dreamed about for a
really long time and I want to thank
this series from making that possibly
come true if not how dare you false
advertising anyway your chapter was
fantastic basically the premise of this
chapter is that on freak week day two
different genres of music start randomly
playing in the air as well as musical
instruments sort of swell around and
sheet music and everyone's over emotions
are related to how they're actually
affected by that music if they're
affected at all so everyone starts to
kind of get very emotional in different
ways I don't have to tell you every
specific cause I really want you to go
over to whap head and read the chapter I
really think it's wonderful it's got a
lot of action in it it's got a ton of
dialogue which is so fun and really
flushes out the characters and makes
them not stereotypes make some actual
characters so good job pseudonym for me
describes crush our main crush character
as someone with short blue hair painted
nails a floral shirt someone with
confidence and kindness and charisma
doesn't seem like a real person but it's
kind of your optimum supreme real person
and the coolest part is if you don't
cool cuz my shoulders went up to my
earlobes is that crushed he currently is
in love with lace
what potential romantic plot lines could
ensue
and one of my favorite parts of this
whole chapter is that it left on such an
engaging cliffhanger and I quote
suddenly the doors whip open with a bang
and a mysterious figure walks into the
school quote fun storm a congrat
pseudonym for me for such an engaging
and wonderful chapter which brings us to
the chapter prompts for Chapter three
our two broad chapter prompts are that
we want you in Chapter three to create a
villain it can be one of the characters
that art exists it can be whatever that
weird cliffhanger character is that we
left on in Chapter two it can be someone
that doesn't exist yet just create a
very tangible and real and defined
villain we want to use the villain to
create number two the mission that our
characters have to complete throughout
freq week we want to create some sort of
task some sort of journey that we can
watch them either succeed or fail out
there come the giggles and then our very
specific silly prompt for the week is
that we want you to include this phrase
somewhere anywhere in your chapter 3
don't you dare fluff that duck somewhere
in your chapter please remember that the
word count for your submissions is a
maximum of 1500 words also make sure
that you're posting with the hashtag
write English race so we can find it
easily when it's oh now I'm too silly
fanart
we've seen a lot of fan art already
manifesting in this writing with grace
ecosystem that we're building and we
encourage you to actually submit it to
us formally there is a tumblr link down
below that you can go check out and
submit your fan art and you will maybe
get featured on one of these episode wow
I feel like this series has really
officially begun this is so exciting and
you guys are amazing writers and I'm not
saying that in a silly way I'm saying it
in a sincere way thank you so much I
hope you're excited to continue
submitting your creative
pieces of art make sure that you check
out Chapter two a freak week on our
Wattpad profile Wattpad comm slash
writing with and don't forget that
you're writing deadlines for chapter
three is Sunday night thank you guys
again for your submissions so great
proud of you
keep on being silly I don't know if I
got all the correct information in this
video I hope so
[Music]